I can tell you that for me,
I try to really balance both
because I'm kind of a nerd.
So it's important for me to put the effort.
Maya Avni, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm good, Michael.
So great being here.
Well, obviously, you're good because
you're at the GSB right behind you now.
You're not actually
outside in front of the GSB,
but you are in very close proximity, right?
Yeah, that's true.
I'm on campus right now.
Actually, I live here,
so it's really, really nice.
It is, though, sunny,
as you can see in the picture.
So, I like it.
It is. It's beautiful.
Actually, I think this episode is likely,
I think it airs in about December.
So, I'll be getting ready
to come back to campus.
But you've had the privilege
of being on campus
throughout a lot of this covid situation.
So, I'd love to both talk about your journey
going from 8200 to different startups,
as QA to Google, and now most recently,
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
But I'm particularly interested to hear about
how you've dealt with covid
as part of this
incredible business school program
and what the GSB is all about anyways.
Maya, take me back.
First of all, who is Maya all the way back
to the 8200 days?
And how do you go about this path
to end up at the GSB?
Wow.
Okay, so that's a lot.
So, let's start
and if you want to stop me,
just feel free obviously.
So, I think, actually, maybe I can start even
from my high school.
At high school I was a dancer actually,
which is pretty far away from everything
that I'm doing today.
I loved it very much.
And then when it was time
to get to go to the army,
like everyone in Israel,
when you get to the age of 18,
you have to go to the army
I really wanted to do
something super meaningful.
So, I decided to drop
my dancing kind of path
and I went to 8200.
8200 for me was the first time
that I fell in love with technology.
This is how I see it.
First time that you are exposed
in very young age to really some crazy things
that we can do thanks to technology.
I spend there three years
and I really knew that
whatever I'm going to do next
is going to be around technology.
I didn't know what it was going to be,
but I knew technology will definitely be
part of my life going forward.
Amazing.
Yeah, and then after that I did like,
like every Israeli I went to Central America.
Did a few months there,
like clean my head,
thought about what I wanted to do.
When I came back,
I decided to start engineering
in Tel Aviv University.
And while I was doing
my engineering degree,
I started working at Google.
And that was like
a very meaningful stop in my way.
I spent there six years.
I absolutely love the company.
And after six years, I felt like
there are a lot of things out there
that I don't know and I'm not really sure
how I'm going to explore those things.
And then I started to think
about doing an MBA.
By the way, I do want to mention here,
because this is a little bit divergent
from what a lot of people
around the world experience.
Because usually when you go to college
and you study whatever it may be,
you don't go and work full time at a company,
especially on a company like Google
while you're studying in.
And it's well, it's a little bit different.
You go to the army,
you spend quite a few years in the army,
whether it's two, all the way
to some people, six.
And then by the time that you go to college,
you're mature enough to both
handle a full degree,
which is extremely intensive
through your program in Israel,
along with a full time job
for only four years
if you're doing the engineering
and juggling Google.
So, I think that's amazing.
Yeah.
So, I started working at Google
at my second year of the university.
So, it was really challenging.
But I can say that
Google is such an amazing place
in the sense that,
like, my first conversation
with my manager was:
okay, we want to keep you like
the top of your class.
So it's very, very important for us
that you keep putting the effort
that you need in university
and whatever you need.
So, that was really amazing
to kind of combine the both.
Sure.
So, talk to me about this
how do you think about going through an MBA?
Because you're spending six years at Google,
you're doing really amazing work there.
I saw you quite a few times
at Google for Startups Building
just in the months leading up to Stanford.
But what makes you want to go do an MBA,
stop your career wherever it may be,
and go become a student again?
Yeah, I mean, I think the first question
that a lot of people ask themselves is
whether or not MBA really worth it.
You know, it's exactly how you said.
You take two years break
from everything you're doing in your life,
like the opportunity cost here is so big.
You're losing two years of salary.
You're losing two years of maybe promotions
and what you're going to do next.
And a lot of people feel like
maybe it's not the best choice.
Like it really depends on who you ask.
And I totally get that to be honest.
You need to sacrifice a lot.
But then again, you have to ask yourself
why you want to do it
and why you actually are doing that.
And I think that for me, the answer was,
first of all, as I started to say,
I wanted to explore more options.
Here at Stanford, I think about everything
that I did last year.
I'm now on my second year.
So I think about everything
that I did last year.
Where in my life would I have
so many opportunities just kind of squeezed
into this one year that I think about
all the things that I did last year.
Experience in a VC,
in different tech companies, in products,
and things that I never did before.
So, for me, first of all,
it was like a safe space to explore
other things that I've never done.
So, that was first.
The second thing that I think
is even more important
is thinking for the long term.
And this is like the main reason why I'm here,
because thinking for the long term,
I think about who am I, as like,
first of all, employee.
But after that is also
maybe a leader, a manager.
What do I bring to the table.
And I think that in terms of my skill set,
I really wanted to make sure that
I have like a very diverse skill set.
And I wanted to make sure that
when I want to be like a manager,
maybe a founder going forward,
I bring to the table valuable stuff.
Both in terms of skill set,
but also who am I as a person,
what my values are.
And Stanford is a lot about the values
and who you are as a leader.
What kind of things are important for you,
what kind of thing you want to push forward.
And I think that the last thing
that kind of brought me here
was the community.
In a second,
you are part of this amazing community
of like the best people
here in Silicon Valley.
The Israelis are like a very nice group
that we all know each other.
So, Maya, I have to ask you,
I have a few short questions and answers.
Because I think that it's really,
it's incredibly important
to understand the context
of what a business school environment is like.
I did not go to business school myself,
not yet at least.
But I did get to experience from the side
and just hanging out with you around campus,
because especially at Stanford,
it's like all intertwined.
We sometimes go to the same classes.
I believe that you took a class recently
with my girlfriend, right?
And she's in graduate school.
So, quickly, who is the type of person
that you would find at the GSB?
Give me some high level characteristics.
What are they like?
You'll find all types of people,
really, but the best ones.
And what that does mean?
Is that the most hard working,
the most humble, the nicest?
What does it mean, the best people?
I think, yeah, the most humble.
I don't know if the most humble,
but definitely people around here
are very humble.
All of the things that you say are like
everyone is coming
from a very different background.
Having like a different background,
I mean, both industries,
but also from everywhere in the world.
So, yeah, a lot of hardworking people
doing their best, you know,
to excel and be the best
in everything that they're doing.
But also there is a huge emphasis
of what kind of person you are
and like being good people,
being good friend.
What kind of values are important for you.
These are things
that we talk a lot about here.
And actually, you know
one of my impressions by meeting
a lot of the people in your cohort
is that every single person
is a leader in their community.
And when you say the best people,
what I'm thinking to mind
is whatever your circumstances were,
you made the most out of it and beyond,
and you've excelled in your circumstances.
You've helped improve the lives of others.
Talk to me.
So, you mentioned being good people
and being in touch with yourself.
Touchy feely.
I heard about that class
from so many different people.
Why is this a good representation
of what the GSB encompasses?
So, touchy feely,
the official name of the class
is interpersonal dynamics.
I'm just taking the class right now,
this quarter.
And yeah, it is a very special class.
You spend a lot of hours per week
with a very small group of people,
and basically it's kind of a safe place
to work on your communication skills,
and how do people feel about
specific actions that you're doing.
And it helps you understand
what kind of message you deliver
to the other side
and maybe how can you improve
and be more efficient
in the things that you wanted to say
and how you're saying that.
It's actually really interesting
because all the alums,
these early alums at least
that I met like a year ago,
even some that graduated like 20 years ago,
all of them are saying that this was like
the most meaningful experience for them
from the GSB.
So, yeah, so I'm doing it right now.
So, maybe we can speak like in a few weeks
to see whether or not
it's the case for me.
I guess it will be.
So in a higher level,
you're thinking about graduate school
of Business at Stanford and all of sudden
you have a class which is all about working
on your personal skills.
And, you know, people call it touchy feely.
And it sounds to me like, you know,
my perception of the business school
up until now was you're coming,
you're learning how to do accounting,
you're learning how to hire people,
how to fire people and how to raise money.
But it sounds like
it's a little bit more complicated than that.
What do you get out
of a business school program?
And this is especially, I think important
because it's sort of like a black box
to a lot of us in the undergraduate world.
We don't really understand
why would people go to do an MBA
when now there's a lot of movements
that are saying maybe
you can just go into the business world
and get those skills yourself?
Yeah, that's a great question.
And so I think, first of all,
the beautiful thing about Stanford
is from your second quarter here,
you can choose electives
and you can build your own schedule
and kind of focus in on things
that you are interested the most.
So depending on what your goal are,
like people are coming here
wanting to be better in finance and investing.
People are coming here
wanting to build their own startup
and learn more about
entrepreneurship and VC.
So it really depends on what you want,
but you can get everything honestly.
So, it's like one of probably,
one of my advices would be
to come here a little bit focused
on what do you want to achieve here.
Because otherwise you can really get lost
in all the things that you can do here.
But you can really get it all.
So, there are a lot of people here
that are working on their startups,
taking a lot of entrepreneurship classes,
meeting a lot of different VCs.
You know, the guests
that are coming to our classes?
Now it's on Zoom.
So, well, you know less.
But the people that are coming to our classes
are amazing.
Like the people from the best VCs,
entrepreneurs that did like sold one,
two, three, four companies
in millions of dollars
can tell us all about their path.
Other people that are coming from PE,
private equity,
and other investment background
can get a lot of background about finance,
accounting, all the things that you did.
And everyone are putting a lot of effort also
into more soft skills.
So presentation skills, communication skills,
role playing about having
difficult conversations and stuff like that,
which is like I really like this.
So, it really depends
on what you're interested in.
But you have here everything honestly.
One focus. One more question about the GSB
and then, I'd love to also focus a little bit
about who you are and some of the things
that you're really passionate about.
But first, how much do you actually work
in the GSB?
Like how much of it is actually
doing homework, sitting down,
solving problem sets,
like I'm doing about 23 hours a day
in the undergraduate world,
versus the networking in the community?
Yeah.
So, once again,
it's a question of who you are
and what's important for you.
People who came here and want to put
like 100% in the academics part,
can spend 20, 40 hours a week
just doing homework and working for classes.
Other people, I think most of the people
who came here came over for the network.
So,  it's really important
to get to know people have coffee chats,
like we have once in a while.
And I can tell you that for me,
I try to really balance both
because I'm kind of a nerd.
So,  it's important for me to put the effort
and make sure
that the classes that I'm taking,
I'm taking very seriously
because I want to take the most out of it.
But also meeting new people,
having coffee chat,
and like having some fun with new friends
and expanding my network,
it's super important for me.
This is maybe the main reason
why I came here.
So, I put a lot of effort there as well.
So, Maya, a very meaningful service
in the intelligence unit in the IDF.
Years of experience in the field,
an engineering degree,
six years at Google,
now very soon an MBA from Stanford.
Where are you headed
and what are you really passionate about?
What do you really see yourself
digging into it and making an impact
in what field?
That's such a tough question.
To be honest,
I'm not sure what's the answer
for this question yet.
I can tell you that I did my last six months,
I worked as a product manager at Brex.
Brex is a super cool company,
FinTech company now valued
at three billion dollars.
[--] I believe, right?
Yeah, true. Undergrads, though.
They didn't graduate. But yeah.
And I really enjoyed my time there.
I really liked the product.
It's the first time that I'm doing that.
So, building something
and thinking about the problem,
what the users really want,
thinking about the solution,
how to design it,
then going through the marketing stage,
and how do we launch the product.
I really, really enjoyed that.
So, the way that I see it,
I would love to do something around product.
And I also really enjoyed FinTech.
So, this is an area
that I am passionate about.
I think so many things
are happening right now in this space.
Innovation is just waiting to happen.
This is how I feel.
So, this is something that I'm very,
very passionate about.
But we'll see.
I don't know.
I want to, at least for now,
just to keep the opportunities open
and we'll wait and see.
Right. Is there a specific experience
that you've accumulated so far
that you can really pinpoint them and say:
this is something that
that I learned a tremendous amount,
something that may not be too obvious?
Specifically from Brex?
Either Brex or any of the other job.
Because one of the things
that I'm especially curious about,
especially through this show,
is the non-linear career pathways
that people take.
And like you, like many others,
it's a non-linear career.
It's you're moving from the IDF to studies
to a corporate to a business school,
and you're getting all these
incredible experiences that I'm sure
that when we'll do this chat again
in 10 years
after you've impacted millions of lives
with whatever you'll do,
it's always interesting for me to gather
this insight from along the journey.
So, what are some
pivotal moments in your life
that you really are going back to
and thinking, wow,
I'm so glad that I had that experience,
even though maybe I didn't realize
the value of it at that moment?
I'll give you an answer
that I'm not sure you're going to like,
but I'll try.
I think that one of the most important things
that I learned that change
is always positive, always.
Doing a change,
going outside your comfort zone,
you always learn a lot.
And the things that
are most important to learn about
are the things to understand
what you really want to do,
what really interests you.
Not everybody knows it.
Like what is the perfect job for you?
Why you want to be an entrepreneur?
Is it really the thing for you?
Why you want to go to product?
Like try to understand exactly
what you're looking for,
like what is your perfect role,
what is your perfect company,
and try to understand the why.
I think these are kind of the questions
that I've been asking myself a lot lately.
And these are the type of questions,
type of answer is more accurately
that will help me shape my next step
and understand what kind of job I want to do
that will make me feel happy,
make me feel like I have a huge impact.
So, in every time that I did a change,
that helped me to take another step forward
to understand the answers to those questions.
Amazing.
Maya, I want to thank you again
for being so generous with your time.
I did like that answer very, very much.
And I want to thank you also
for being such a pivotal
and important part of my journey at Stanford.
So, we are countless coffee chats
and your help with everything.
It's warming to have such
a strong Israeli society within Stanford.
Like half of my professors
somehow every quarter are Israeli,
which is just phenomenal.
But having classmates and people
that I can look up to, like yourself
that are helping along the journey.
So, thank you for that.
Before we go, I have the last question,
the most important one,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
That's a tough one.
Okay. For me will be friend,
curious, and problem-solver.
You'll give me the last one
as as if it was a one word.
There is a hyphen in there.
Exactly.
Friend, curious, and problem solver.
Maya, thank you very much. Toda raba.
Best of luck with finishing this year
at the GSB.
I definitely hope to see you either
in January or in March
when I'm finally back on campus.
And I can be in that wonderful weather.
Not that it's not that bad in Tel Aviv,
I have to say about the weather,
but I think there is less protests
on the streets of Stanford right now.
But I'm looking forward
to seeing you again soon.
Thank you, Michael.
Looking forward.
Bye. Take care.